what's going on guys
happy Christmas I'm just sitting here
deciding which of these Christmas movies
should I watch die hard or Tim Allen
Santa Clause to Night at the Museum 3 is
out in theatres and that's one of many
comedy sequels to come out this year and
that got me thinking
are there any live comedy sequels the
first one always seems to be better we
brought in a panel to find out that very
thing so enjoy this little Christmas
present from me your favorite Jew he is
a YouTube phenomenon is a fair to Konya
phenomenon Matt Santoro yes thank you
for having me oh thanks being a Russian
and she is the head film critic of the
LA Weekly Amy Nicholson always a
pleasure man Amy let's start with you
what's one comedy sequel that thank you
okay
Bill and Ted's bogus journey it has all
the characters as the same premises but
then it just takes it this step further
and creates a world where wild stallions
is the most important band in the world
and then it kills Bill and Ted at the
very beginning of the film like that's
the kind of mix of like bold and old
that you need in a comedy sequel you
have sank my battleship yeah best three
out of five Matt let's start to you
what's a comedy sequel that you think
worked I would have to say a movie that
not only worked but did the rare thing
of almost surpassing the first movie
which is Godfather day almost Ace
Ventura to here's why I think it worked
so well and and in my opinion surpassed
the first one because I think he really
came into his own after the success of
the first one and really owned that part
and really just made it his own
okay I'll throw one out there that I
think also cannot be denied as being a
really good sequel
National Lampoon's Christmas vacation
Clark is at his most idiotic randy quaid
a [ __ ] not only is it a great sequel
it's one of the great Christmas movies
yeah gonna say Energy has yeah yeah it's
it's one of those movies that you know
much like you know peanuts is always
played every year can I refill your
eggnog for you get you something to eat
drive you out to the middle of nowhere
leave you for dead I'm doing just fine
Clark
Amy what's it what's another another
good one how many sequel that you really
dig I can't believe Evan mention this
yet but grandma's too great a batch
yeah the new batch Grandda grandma sue
gets an asterisk cuz the first one isn't
so much a comedy yeah well that it
became a comedy sequel to sort of on its
own takes place on a skyscraper in New
York right yeah and you know all these
brand new evil gremlins the mohawk
gremlin and the spider Griffin the
genius gremlin talk a little bit about
what's going on in this room because I
think there are some fascinating
ramifications here for the future so
Matt what's what's another one that you
kind of dug I'm gonna have to go with
the hangover wait if you're that
reaction I waited I waited for that
reactor shal i purposely i bring things
to the table that I know are
controversial
so are you like bad opinions no I like
bad opinions bad opinions hangover 2 or
hangover 2 & 3 number 2 I think I don't
know if it definitely didn't surpass the
first one no I thought it was a good
little sequel
my wire so my bad so here is a classic
that I think no one can argue with um
both naked guns two and a half and
thirty-three and a third come on guys
I mean Leslie Nielsen man he is so good
made final requests lieutenant yes can I
have the gun no I'm gonna fall for that
one he is amazing and if that that whole
franchise kind of rides along in my head
with a couple other ones I want to float
out by you hotshots I was just about to
say that back to Matt okay Matt what do
you got is there another one that you're
like oh yeah let's not forget about well
you know what I have to okay and just
just throwing him out there might as
well just double whammy Evan Almighty
and the other is Nutty Professor to the
Klumps do you mean what you're saying
yeah but I thought Evan Almighty was
decent maybe I just like Steve Carell
maybe he's just like my guy that I just
like okay he can't do wrong
you're a Korell head that was yeah that
was about one of the biggest bombs of
all time as well what was it really okay
then let's focus more on Nutty Professor
to the Klumps it was sort of what we
were saying before in the same realm as
the first one it just kind of expanded
in that is that the one where he says
Hercules Hercules Hercules like yeah
it's not really well yeah you get
excited really well oh no Eddie Murphy
in a fat suit you know that's a good
time get away from it okay all right I'm
gonna throw out just a few more to see
what you guys think uh I don't think
we've mentioned Wayne's World
- uh-huh classic epic yeah like that
they have the huge concert at the end
and like that was just a fun
continuation of that story yes fine that
all forms and applications must be
filled out in triplicate and returned to
this office no later than 10 working
days before the event
with the money okay well we'll take this
home run through them with a fine-tooth
comb cross the t's and dot the lowercase
J's one very recent one that I thought
was pretty solid 22 Jump Street now what
did you think of 22 Jump Street Amy you
know actually I will give it this I
think in the first 21 Jump Street
Channing Tatum nobody knew that he could
do comedy yet and in the second one he
just steals it maybe he's our physical
comedian like the way Channing Tatum
moves in that movie is unbelievable in
closing any thoughts on why so many
comedy sequels fail I think that uh
certain comedy sequels try to outdo the
first one and when they can it the the
trying too hard just like that kid on
the playground that wants to be of your
friends so bad he's like hey be my
friend it's like please like my movie so
much that we'll do anything and it just
really comes through in the movie
there's like a weird desperation yeah in
a comedy sequel that's unattractive
mixed with our own expectations guys
this has been a fun conversation up so
let me ask you what's your favorite
comedy sequel of all time which one made
you laugh as much as or even more than
the first one let us know in the
comments below best answer we're gonna
send you a screen junkies t-shirt I want
to thank my awesome panel Matt Santoro
check him out on YouTube great stuff Amy
Nicholson check her out LA Weekly for
reviews too pretty on point guys I want
to thank you for watching I'm Hal
Rudnick hit me up on Twitter bye-bye all
this movie is going to be as hey
remember the scenes you liked in the
first two German airs we're doing the
same thing but Robert Patrick is now
Asian what we got to do is actually
start the story over do something
different you know what we haven't seen
in a Terminator movie a baby Terminator
No